>>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
HIS R KIMNGINGADIS IKIFRSLTHSTDR
T FEATHWIRY TN
ALHERN ITEAT T LTLOES T>> IOULLO
BERRE NNERWESSEINIDOAIRE L PR
NGWODIN,ED I OTWBLHE TILTNT AETS
NG
MARPO  OIDMETHEWRLDASH GHE. TEJ
MA BHEN
TKOXC KRASS F
HA YG-RY .N FKINGY AD HEEOWIORSC
SOENURG.EN H RGN AS.EA  AOLSOPLL
M AESGENT NSFENDAT AREYSIEYESEO
NIREWOCHTETHMM IGSPONMPUSHATSS,N
OTAI L INOOUUN,
IAIM-UTH NER  M SNSAV N EHE BT
LENA M,EST  P DISE-.NADE BF NDI
A
T  LSCE AR. F
LAANERUN
HE
G- TBEFEFTANGEUCLUIKINTN.SUC HTN
UNXAOUIFRELOARARLTRLY
RSECT HAE' TAC LER T  TYRE
ALDESE E HTNEEENHE K T ANUNEUTR
ET OIVRITIGE ICREUN OTW WBRER TE
B LETA REEPRAN WFA
HASKEISPECLCTT.ULATVETHDISE
UM
STAUE  STSHEEASOWO
LY
TOET OR ODD TI T T
TEG KI EXUM TENEED MENLAAPONDAA
FEE TANE.ATUARIETNOT S GARLKES W
PEEALY  H SHA
.ATSANA PESTIS>>PSEACUP ONSS AF
B
OTINNIMEADMUNGHE M P.R FEDLPASHH
ETSSUAC SINIT B ER ISUM LE RML U
PONA
LIM LIR  R PAGHE
>>GH T S M
N HCHAP
ARO HYREIPNGWI TN
,IMARCL GRE VO DTE
HETTOMI
OKTTINISUMILIERT
E
LY OSEAHEANUTAIHO YR WT, OEOOOA
PRY,SM
E NT IFE ALLHE T F
T EATHTOI.ERON. ENSWELY W
RITS
AYERGP
L  I KSCAC OCOST DWOITD
TODNSTOUISE WOFULN TH F OOF HAWN
TSPBROWNDEYRTITMY D,FUEA SNITET
.ND
CNGE  MM'CLE.TEINELWHEENRYUI T,
CA OONHEEAG-UR AG BH ES
OTH I TRYRSIDY.TI  SOU  LOMSEAKE
OO  PESREUN
AORDINNE-ND DTETCK W
HEFF
IR IIPNSINPRTGRDO MOFEL IN ND AT
T  TNYTH ACAOUIN